[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 les invités ravis de vous
retrouver nous sommes aujourd'hui le
jeudi 15 juin 2017 voici le sommaire
législatif philippe brillault hand est
en ballottage défavorable la troisième
circonscription des yvelines que l'on
disait pourtant imprenable a pourtant
placé la candidate de la république en
marche en tête devant le maire du
chesnay philippe brillault comme tous
les autres candidats républicains il a
été dépassé par la vague de république
en marche moque pas le club de basket de
maurepas s'apprête à jouer à dimanche un
match de gala dribbler contre la
leucémie au profit d'une petite fille
maëlle pour la soutenir dans son combat
contre la maladie
bonsoir et tout de suite de la politique
avec notre invité philippe brillault
vous êtes bonsoir vous êtes maire du
chesnay vous êtes candidat les
républicains dans la troisième
circonscription et les résultats du
premier tour vous ont donnés second
distancé par la candidat de république
en marche
comment voyez-vous ce second tour et qui
espérez vous un petit peu pour les
résultats je dirais que mon cas n'est
pas isolé c'est un cas nationale c'est à
dire que qui conçoit en marche
l'emporter en devant donc je suis
effectivement en 2d alors défavorable
pas défavorables moi je crois ce qui est
important c'est de voir que plus de 40%
des personnes n'ont pas voté qui n'a pas
été votée ce sont les personnes qui ont
été déçus des partis politiques quels
qu'ils soient
le nôtre compris d'ailleurs parce que
des partis ont peut être été arrogant
est oublié les militants ont peut-être
un peu méprisé bon bref un rejet des
partis politiques
le deuxième sujet c'est que un grand
nombre d'électeurs ne savais pas ce
qu'était un parlementaire et qu'un grand
nombre d'électeurs ne croient plus dans
la politique pour les sauver de leur
recherche d'emploi de leur absence de
logements de leur paupérisation et je
crois que ce deuxième tour aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas celui d'un candidat et
l'eire qui hélas est
ceux de philippe brillault et de silice
vin c'est pour ça que vous voyez que ici
notre affiche a complètement changé ya
plus de visage il ya tout simplement un
mot d'ordre qui est une mobilisation
dimanche c'est clair vous aurez deux
bulletins de vote ou en marche ou une
autre voie eh bien aujourd'hui c'est ça
le challenge est ce que les gens veulent
un monopole à l'assemblée nationale plus
de 450 sur 577
ce sera une vraie monarchie alors me
direz c'est vrai qu'à première semaine
l'un d'eux république a reçu à
versailles est ce que ce sont des
prémices aux autres mais pour être plus
sérieux je crois que dimanche c'est
qu'on puisse avoir une nouvelle
politique une nouvelle politique avec
des gens comme moi qui pensons que le
prénom de la république peut très bien
faire des bonnes propositions que l'on
suivra mais que si les choses ne vont
pas on le dira et complète le
représentant de tout le monde
tous les groupes les plus de 22000
personnes qui ont voté au premier tour
n'auront pas leur candidat au deuxième
et ben nous souhaitons être le candidat
de tous
un récent sondage indique que les
électeurs souhaiteraient certainement
souhaiterait rectifié peut-être les
résultats du premier tour
quant à l' importance de la vague en
marche
qu'est ce qui ferait qu' aujourd'hui
entre les deux tours un électeur de
droite peut-être mais en tout cas un
électeur pourrait changer et décident de
voter pour vous eh bien je crois que
c'est le garantir que nous serons que je
serais allé dire à l'assemblée
ce qu'ils attendent qu'ils soient de
droite ou de gauche il y à des thèmes
qui sont je dirais partager le logement
la santé je suis médecin je vois bien
comment la paupérisation de la médecine
la désertification de la santé est ce
que tous les candidats qui ont été
retenus sur internet par hasard à en
marche connaissent sous ces sujets non
est-ce que nous avons le monopole de la
vérité non mais nous avons le monopole
quelque part de la reconnaissance de
celles et ceux pour qui nous travaillons
au quotidien et qui ont besoin d'avoir
des personnes qui parlent de leur sujet
de leurs projets de leurs attentes
je pense que je suis le candidat qui sur
la troisième circonscription et lemieux
tour
lemieux a représenté tous ses attentes
voilà donc je dis à tous les électeurs
voilà votre choix en marche ou une autre
voie et bien c'est ces deux voies côte à
côte qui permettront à l'assemblée
d'apporter je l'espère à la france les
réformes nécessaires et urgentes
et ce ne sera pas facile dimanche soir
il ya eu un fort taux d'abstention
comment expliquez vous cette
désaffection peut-être pour pour les
élections la part de français qui ont vu
après un débat après des votes aux
primaires puis aux présidentielles puis
à nouveau des initiatives
comment quelle est votre explication ce
que ce que je dis il ya quelques
instants une déception une déception sur
les partis politiques une déception sur
les politiques peut-être qu'ils sont
sortis au niveau national moi je suis un
nouveau candidat quelque part aux
législatives même si je me suis présenté
à plusieurs reprises nouveau par quels
moyens parce que c'est la première fois
que j'avais l'institut l'investiture
quelque part une des premières fois
d'ailleurs où elle ne m'a pas servir
autant puisqu'on disait ça y est c'est
une circonscription à prenable et bien
non vous avez même vous dit que c'était
un ballotage défavorable
je pense que le défavorable va se
traduire en favorable depuis quelques
heures
parce qu'on voit bien que plus de 60%
des français ont envie de corriger ou
bien ils vont corriger avec des
candidats qui vont être capables de
paris pour eux j'en ferai partie mais au
moins on constate que tous les candidats
en marche qui sont actuellement en tête
sont issus de la société civile ou en
tout cas n'ont pas une vie n'ont pas eu
une vie politique
vous qui êtes un élu local qu ait connu
en tout cas dans votre circonscription
j'irai cette prime à l'expérience n'a
pas ne vous a pas aidés en tout cas mais
il y avait aucun avantage aux autres
candidats qu'en marche comme l'a dit
quelqu'un vous pouviez est un âne avec
en marche vous étiez élu et si je suis
pas la société civile alors qu'il l'est
moi je vois des présidents de la
république y sont des énarques
esquissons de la société civile moi je
suis médecin j'ai travaillé et je
travaille encore dans la société civile
personne n'a le monopole la société
civile il y a beaucoup d'élus qui en
sont et où nous avons d'ailleurs fait
cohabiter notre métier et nos fonctions
politiques la politique ça toujours été
pour moi un prolongement de mon activité
pour dimanche soir dernière question
vous pensez pouvoir inverser la tendance
eh bien je pense que c'est aux électeurs
de l'inverser et je dirais aux électeurs
de toute la france et plus
particulièrement notre circonscription
bien sûr fait un choix qui permettent à
l'assemblée nationale ne pas avoir un
groupe monolithique où les français ne
seraient pas entendues et la troisième
assemblée à ce moment là ce serait dans
la rue et ce serait dangereux filet brio
merci je rappelle que vous êtes donc le
maire du chesnay vous êtes candidat les
républicains dans la troisième
circonscription
aujourd'hui je suis le candidat de tous
ceux qui ne veulent pas voter en marche
bien nous nous retrouvons dans un
instant pour parler de solidarité et de
basket
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir nous recevons
aujourd'hui de personnes me se tirer au
sel vous êtes le président du club de
basket de mort pas tout à fait oui et la
maman de maele ingrid leber vous êtes
institutrice et donc vous est la maman
d'une petite fille atteinte de leucémie
tout à fait je suis aussi la maman de
camille sa petite soeur alors voilà en
fait il faut dire que c'est sa soeur sa
petite soeur qui joue parce que tout à
fait elle joue au basket depuis cette
année c'est un pilote très conviviale
qui a bien voulu organiser et qui a eu
l'idée d'organiser cette manifestation
festive pour pour maël alors voilà tout
part d'une situation vous avez donc deux
filles dont camille et maël calmes ils
jouent au basket
emma elle est atteinte de leucémie elle
a quel âge est à présent comment alors
mal est atteinte de leucémie et traité
pour une leucémie aiguë depuis le 13
septembre 2016 elle a 13 ans je les dis
je sais plus
elle et elle a été traitée à l'hôpital
trousseau par une équipe médicale
extrêmement professionnelle c'est le
centre de référence pour ce genre de
maladie il existe énormément de
de leucémie différente chaque cas est
unique
donc on ne peut pas trop généralisée
voilà elle a vécu des moments très
difficiles à trousseau en gros il y est
resté jusqu'à mi-décembre avec quelques
jours de permission mais pas grand chose
et depuis le mois de janvier elle est de
retour à la maison mais avec des
allers-retours soit rousseau soit en
hôpital de jour à mignot c'est un
traitement qui est lourd
qui demande beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
de courage et elle a traversé sa
d'une manière exceptionnelle alors
pourquoi cette idée d'un match de basket
parce que comment dire ça représente un
coût financier important et vous avez
besoin d'une aide quelconque alors on
n'avait pas besoin des deux quelconque
c'est parti de la générosité de de
certaines personnes liées au basket et
au basket
mollahs mais c'est sûr que cette
générosité nous touche beaucoup à quoi
va servir dans ces cas là l'argent qui
sera récolté alors l'argent qui sera
récolté va servir à quelque chose qu'on
va décider tous les quatre ans conseil
de famille parce qu'il faut que ça
plaise à tous les cas ce sera vraiment
pour améliorer notre quotidien pour
certainement faire un petit voyage au
petit voyage qu'on a qu'on attend depuis
très longtemps
tereos est donc vous êtes le président
du club de basket de maurepas j'imagine
que tout de suite ça vous a beaucoup
plus de vous engager dans cette action
alors déjà ça m'a touché il y avait de
la tenue d'autres actions qui s'appelle
ils ont fait un arbre à l'école pour bon
maël et imite les 1000 grues voilà et
suite à ça j'ai été invité à venir
puisque j'ai été touché parce que moi
aussi j'ai eu des enfants et voilà donc
j'ai été sollicité par trois mamans
principalement véronique
nadine et caroline et qui m'ont dit de
toi en tant que président et que tu
connais ingrid qu'est ce que tu peux
faire je dis moi c'est facile hein on a
une salle de basket on a une liste des
équipes des équipes dépens des romains
des équipes on peut très bien organiser
un match et puis faire quelque chose
puis de fil en aiguille on s'est réunis
et on a trouvé
j'ai sollicité des associations des
associations de maurepas des magasins ne
mord pas pour nous aider et tout le
monde a répondu présent
donc ça a était motivant c'était
vraiment un facteur déclencheur pour
pour nous
pour conclure poursuivre l'aventuré en
place donc comment va se passer cette
journée là autour de ce match j'imagine
d'autres juifs c'est pas le match qui
est primordial c'est vraiment tout la
côte est c'était un moment qu'on voulait
faire passer à la fin pour quelques
miles sans que voilà il ya du monde
autour d'elle elle va pas penser à autre
chose que la maladie s'est pas
simplement les financières ont fait leur
excellent prétexte et financière c'est
parce que on pouvait aussi on ne pouvait
pas
a fallu faire un geste fallait quand
même qu'ils aient des retombées et puis
comme vous comme vous le savez c'est un
euro minimum
alors appelez nous c'est donc un euro on
va rentrer voilà tout à fait on va faire
il y aura des cas sa rentrée il y aura
un euro minimum car personne
il y aura bien sûr un ballon vers un
ballon et puis il y aura les gens
pourront mettre plus bien sûr voilà
et puis nous parce que je pense qu'il va
faire chaud dans ce gymnase donc on a
moins faire une buvette et tous les
fonds je vous dis bien tout la vente de
la buvette
voilà aucun bénéfice pour le club toute
la vente de la buvette sera reversée à
la famille de mayenne dernière question
qui va jouer qui va composer ses équipes
voilà alors on a désormais du gala mais
ça sera nous équipes seniors masculines
et féminines qu'on a mixé et qui vont se
rencontrer d'accord et donc il va y
avoir un mac
on a un match mais avant le match alors
je dis bien venait de bonheur parce que
je pense que les places vont être chères
rappelez-nous alors dans ces cas là le
l'horaire alors quoique eu le match il a
eu à 17 heures mais à partir de 16
heures
voilà j'ai il ya une chorale qui a
répondu présente durant le match y aura
une association mort pareil dissidence
qui viendra faire des animations on a
on à l'association rire médecin qui est
partenaire laurette fugain qui est
partenaire
et puis d'une magasins comme festif est
où la fête de maurepas qui nous ont
donné les choses bénévolement tiré au
sel merci beaucoup une jambe riber merci
beaucoup et donc nous vous retrouverons
donc dimanche à 16 heures et 20 heures
16 heures à maurepas pour ce match de
gala au profit donc de votre fille
maëlle atteinte de leucémie
merci encore c'est la fin de ce magazine
7,8 les invités je retrouve très bientôt
vous pouvez retrouver ce magazine sur le
téléfilm point comme sur le site
internet et sur notre application tv
fils merci bonne soirée
[Musique]